hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play
oh hey sedale oh sorry I have some stuck
in my throat
give me while I call from my goblet like
a bow uh-huh apologies apologies okay
here we go
lowering wet when we laugh when we last
left off uh-huh
I can't talk today when we last left off
we had just put three fuses in howevers
in the ever we realized that we the save
mechanic work that you needed more pages
and so I might be a little bit behind
where it was so I gotta go back upstairs
and find out where I left off which is
gonna be so much fun
II okay where am I where where where am
i what have I got
oh maybe I did put it in maybe I did
maybe I did okay well let's check up
anyway because we got to go back
upstairs with that girl I don't want to
date you I'm too good for you I'm don't
you know who I am I am the incredible
markiplier everybody wants a piece of me
was it in here yeah I was in here oh I
did not put it in I did Joey up you
[ __ ] man I go solo okay I only got
there supposedly there are three more
fuses that need to be put into somewhere
but I don't know where so I'm just gonna
do from the top down and hope that lady
doesn't pop up anywhere cuz I mean she's
nice at all she's nice she's nice but um
but um but um but um but um I Drive I
need to figure out how to get into the
steam gassy room cuz unless I can find a
gas mask I'm gonna be pretty much well
and truly Baba boned damn under nothing
here there ain't no thing here wait was
these what been here what about my
brother what are you what are you solid
idea red tee oh whoa
no thank you I don't want any going down
here screw you I'm not even gonna give
you a chance to get to me
it's screw you there's bound to be like
I dunno
cuz this says that we need to banish the
demon child with I don't know what those
are lights look like lights of some sort
spotlights maybe spotlights from the
ceiling good go down to the no okay
nevermind
but it's gotta be them glibly rah
oh here's another one oopah D bump into
me bit about I don't have that one I
thought I taw I have a red one
there's gotta be more fuses here no I go
ha ha ha
there's gotta be more fuses nut up put a
[ __ ] I click up the stupid mouse goes
outside the window I can't I can't never
mind oh never mind never mind
ah spotlight oh that's what I'm gonna
get oh oh oh I put a holliford go I'm
supposed to be finding those two
schnikeys I'm gonna be searching through
all the rooms again bird I swear I
didn't see any of those unlock you [ __ ]
unlock you bastard
let me through ok anyway let me just
search through every single room again
looking for some sort of secret lamp
type device lamp Euler its its it's a
lamp istic in shape and size and girth
nothing I still don't know what those
fuses are for but I'm I'm willing to bet
that there's some goodies in that steam
room hi where's my reflection --ax
Pollux Pollux
watch Oh what Alex Alex Alex Alex Alex
Alex why wait what are you doing there
buddy
is there another mirror in here why what
why okay never mind
this is searched through every room
again okay so I'm looking for spotlight
type devices while escaping the demonic
entity that is trying to hunt my dreams
and my reality cuz she's right here
what's behind door number two demon oh
ah Damon Damon where is he where is he
where is he where is he I'm stuck on a
desk where is she Ziva
come on stay away okay look for a lamb
lamb type device nothing okay alright
then we're okay Brooke we're all right
why are these doors all closed now you
were close before look for a lamp type
device lamp I love lamb I love lamp I
love lamb
there's no lamp I am so full okay hey
and there's a lamp in here I remember
oh Allah PA okay you got two holidays
all right I don't know why that one got
me so good oh my god I can't die cuz I
haven't I don't have any papers to save
with did I see anything in here actually
er no no I did not okay get out here get
out of here get out of here go on I'll
let you go get out of here ah the
legends were true he really is super
sand lesbian bad anyone [ __ ] Eng love
that guy
I'm spitting all over myself okay we're
gonna be fine we're gonna bop [ __ ] it
steam room can't go in there or else
I'll die I'll die a horrible horrific
death why can't I go in these rooms why
not why why I want to go in I have keys
don't I know I do not never mind I was a
lie I ain't no key I just I'll just try
to get you now
get out get down that's the alarm to
signal that she's on her way just stayed
out here a cool off for a bit whoa
wala la la la la la la la la why sure
there wasn't something like in the back
room of the library maybe because I
wasn't looking for it in the beginning I
didn't see it like a lamp of some sort
oh no can I go back I'm gonna go back I
want to see the other monster the other
monster was much better than this one
yeah
don't be making weird noises Dada
alright whatever I don't care if I could
read that maybe that would help me Oh's
inna hala photos on the pho taste acerca
maja fallar a potay are coated hairy so
Nuka okay I can't read that I'm too
stupid to be dad I'm too stupid to even
try I'm too stupid to play this way was
it no this is a whole norm I'm too
stupid to even play this game okay let
me just search wait ah [ __ ] shut up
shut up lady you think you're so cool
you're weird
hey red wing I'm a baby I'm a big baby I
thought I saw something on top of the
locker here but it was just a shadow
never mind let's just go in the rooms
again searching for a lamp aha lamp
I love lamp all right let's don't go
back down just yet let's keep searching
I must have missed something else
because these are kind of hard I go I
run run run run run run run run run run
run run run oh you [ __ ] damn it dang
god you're so stupid
I don't have a save I can't save you
almost got meows oh come on uh screwed
I'm gonna assume that those are not
connected to the actual appearance of
this lady and I haven't found nearly
enough lamps I don't even know how to
get into the other place the steam room
Oh ha I don't know what's worse is if I
don't solve this now I'm not gonna be
able to save cuz I don't have frickin
paper Virge frickin
frak oh they're nothing in here is there
nothing for me there's nothing for me
here only death destruction
dismemberment I must I was hoping that
maybe like one of the lockers or trash
cans would hold something for me but
nothing
I told nothing that's all a lie there's
got to be what I'm assuming is there's a
key that helps me get into here that
that will turn off the steam what I
can't get it I can't get it I cannot get
it I can't
oh maybe like an I don't know maybe if I
look in one of the sinks it seems like a
place where they'd hide a small key I
guess come on give it to me give it to
me now give me the key now come with me
if you want to what what can I do that
to all of them that was what their note
it said three times on the toilet I need
to flush all these toilets to flush out
her spirit ha
Acho beta fall tada monado Alex Alex
Alex I did some weird ritual I don't
know what though I didn't know you could
flush those okay only those not these
does man what was it
I did something something got triggered
maybe the steam room opened up I don't
know I don't know why my boat - no my my
motor no autopilot Alex Alex Alex can I
still flush it
come on hurry up your back flush flush
flush away the evil spirits nurse okay
already flesh so Alex how exact bollocks
bollocks
alright there's no oh there we go or dem
something triggered I don't know what
same thing as before steam room
ROG I'm not about to get out of here
hahahaha Pro dodge ah I am so great I'm
so great I'm so great oh yeah look at me
I'm sorry okay anyway yeah there's got
to be a key somewhere oh there's gotta
be something else something I'm missing
something that I am missing what time I
missing I do not know I do not near you
red light give me your essence want to
open us I want to do a lot of things but
apparently I cannot I saved too much I
do not have paper to save cuz that's
really stupid there's paper everywhere
what kind of use that okay whatever
I've just got to take one last look and
then I'll be well I'll be out of time
look seriously what were they doors I
want a open turkey on ground there's
something on ground [ __ ] you I don't
have this here's a lot up I found the
last two fuse boxes but I don't have the
last two fuses or no there's three more
I don't know how many there more are Oh
what am i doing hah
stream it right it's really loud for one
thing oh I did your bathroom Chan what
you want from me maybe there's like
another one of these poster boards that
I can grab some more paper from or maybe
there's a lamp hidden somewhere or maybe
nothing's really hidden and they're just
in the doors that I can't I know how to
get in either way I don't know I I'm at
a loss about to loss I'm so lost hi
hello you're just gonna stand there
hi I don't know I don't know everybody I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know good a lot a win like I said
before I'm so bad at games apparently
I'm just so bad I can't find a key I
don't know just tell me what to do
everybody so I can get out of this
living hell
so anyway that's it for now I'll have to
backtrack again but next time I'll play
forward and then start recording after
I've caught up so tell me what to do in
the comments so plan for yourself figure
it out you try this you try it so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
ah
but
hey why are you